HE WORKS ON DURANT.
DOWN GOES MATTHEWS.
GIANNIS BACK IN.
HE HAS GOT 37.
OVER DRUMMOND.
PICKED OFF.
BROWN.
OUTLET THE OTHER WAY AND HERE
COMES MIDDLETON.
>> Reggie: BROWN SLOWED DOWN
GIVING A CHANCE FOR MIDDLETON TO
CATCH UP.
HE MADE A PLAY TRYING TO GO
AFTER THE BALL.
BROWN SEES HIM IN THE REARVIEW
MIRROR.
IT IS JUST A HARD FOUL.
HE GETS THE ARM.
HE WAS GOING FOR THE BALL.
IT IS THE OPTICS MAKES IT LOOK
BAD.
THIS IS A SCARY FALL.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
THAT IS A SCARY FALL.
>> Kevin: MIDDLETON PICKED UP
HIS THIRD FOUL.
>> Kevin: BROWN IS A TOUGH ONE.
BROWN, TONIGHT WITH 19 POINTS
HIT THREE THREES.
HIS SHOOTING HAS BEEN OFF OF THE
CHARTS.
THE BEST SHOOTING STRETCH OF HIS
FOUR-YEAR CAREER IS RIGHT NOW
AND HE CREDITS THE ASSISTANT
COACH KYLE KORVER FOR HIS
SHOOTING.
>> Reggie: DOES MIDDLETON HOLD
HIM TO THE GROUND?
WE HAVE THE LUXURY OF SUPER
SLOW.
HERE IS THE FOUL, OBVIOUSLY.
I THINK IT IS A COMMON FOUL,
BUMPED UP TO A FLAGRANT 1.
BUT THIS IS A HARD FOUL.
AND MAYBE BRINGING HIM DOWN
RIGHT THERE, I CAN SEE WHERE IT
WOULD BE A FLAGRANT 1.
>> Kevin: THAT IS PROBABLY WHAT
THEY ARE GOING TO LOOK AT IN
WHAT, REGGIE, TO YOU AND I SEEMS
LIKE A DRESS REHEARSAL FOR THE
PLAYOFFS.
>> Reggie: YES.
BOTH TEAMS HAVE A LOT TO PLAY
FOR.
>> Referee: FLAGRANT 2 HAS BEEN
ASSESSED.
>> Kevin: MIDDLETON IS OUT.
GONE.
>> Reggie: A DEFENSIVE PLAYER AS
WELL.
GOING UP FOR THE DUNK.
>> Kevin: HELD ON TO THE ARM.
>> Reggie: HELD ON TO THE ARM.
BROWN EASILY COULD HAVE BROKE AN
ARM ON THE FOUL.
>> Kevin: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
PLAYER WHO HAS TAKEN HIS